welcome to clean's Window Service my
name is Markiplier and
I clean
windows
o oh that's how nice it's kind of like
um reminds me of late night mop in a way
no offense Lix or uh uh offense no it's
not an offending thing why would I even
apologize for that don't be
confused anyway we have some dirty
windows at home
but we are busy during the day so your
job would be done at night we really
need to look out the windows during the
day don't worry about it though you will
be paid up front you know I wasn't
really worried about it
before now I am I will send you the
address to you now now to you do do you
and now thank
you really truly thank you for this
thank you thank you very much thank
you thank
you markip bl's Window Cleaning Service
how can I clean you
[Music]
oh well ain't this
nice ah Swanky oh how do you get your
car out of
there H maybe they just blast through
the bushes every time they just get them
replanted all right I don't need
anything to start cleaning right I can
just go use this
water uh
hello oh oh oh wait that's mine that's
my
truck
wait am I doing
that what all the lights oh
oh
ah I'm trying I'm really
trying oh that's nice oh look at that
it's actually got some fluid Sim stuff
going on
wow well that's
impressive all
right oh look at
this oh well this is just lovely you
know this isn't so bad
oh
okay I didn't know we were getting into
Power wall simulator territory that's
pretty pretty all right all right next
window thank you this is
suspicious I
think
uhhuh H is that on the inside or
what it's not
suspicious oh man but I sprayed so good
I wish I could use my mouse to flip back
and forth that'd be nice or my keyboard
okay next
window
hi who are
you how are you doing good
good let me actually do the oh never
mind dust first
then hello don't mind me just the window
guy you know I've seen many of horror
game that has this perspective but from
the inside and you watch something
horrible on the
outside uh-huh scrub a dub duub scrub a
d duub scrub a du duub hey okay
hi hello I would never ever do
that I don't know how people could
possibly be this
comfortable lovely
window get a high
score have a good day
so it seems like no matter what I got to
spray in between each time so I'll do
that what am I seeing in
there probably nothing probably nothing
definitely nothing definitely
nothing
sh this
well okay seems like we got a spider
problem in there but uh not my
job not my
job see see I I I feel
like all right whatever this is
fine hello hi hello don't mind me just
the window
man sco
sco yeah I don't know why I'm being
suspicious at all there's nothing unto
here except the mask that's over
there
whoa
oh
ah
ah what am I hearing probably nothing
probably the TV or something you
watching TV in there
good good don't mind me how did these
windows get so dirty if you don't mind
me
asking
why is it not clean oh there we
go
hi
[Music]
hello
what was that there was something right
there didn't like what I
saw my bottle is empty better grab some
more cleaner from the back of my truck I
better I better do that I don't know how
that would have gotten on the outside
had a crazy Halloween huh
huh hey did you get a high score where'd
you
go must drop my
[Music]
keys I like that I have one big key
makes it easy hopefully there's nothing
behind
me
huh it's a little
[Music]
suspicious okie dokie
then hey wait a minute hey wait a minute
hey hey wait a
minute
all right you know it's one of those
things where so far nothing strange has
really happened I saw a pretty butterfly
and has been really nice and maybe I'm
just operating under the assumption that
these are horror games there's that mask
again but maybe there's nothing unto
occurring
oh see I feel like if I spray again it
should it should do it for me like
that all right
now you see this is a little suspicious
I can't help but feel that that's it's
just
like slightly concerning cuz that is
that even on the
outside it it doesn't make a lot of
sense for that to be on the
outside
hi that's fine are you the window
cleaning murderer
good God I'm I got to fix that I'm just
operating under the assumption
that hi how you doing all back there oh
man that's
nice should I warn
you should I warn
anybody
about the horrific murder Roar you
know ah hi oh Fe feel like it's it's not
my job I don't care many murderers
inside what kind of crazy orgy Murder
Party they're having I don't judge I'm a
very objective window cleaner it's n in
my business I don't snitch I don't do
nothing people want to throw big old
murder parties it's none of my business
so long as they don't make the windows
actually they can make the windows as
dirty as they want more business for me
am I
right I don't care what bodily fluids I
got to clean up from these windows ain't
my
business I just I just clean the windows
no questions
asked la la la la la
la
I didn't see
nothinga
ah almost got it all in one that would
have been
something oh anyway spotless I don't do
inside cleaning it's not part of my job
I don't care about blood on the inside
whatever fluids none of my
business
windows
now that's nice where' the knife go not
my problem there was a knife on the
table right there but again not my
problem I don't judge that's not my
purview purview is a word that you guys
should understand here's a definition of
it not
mine
that's awfully awfully convenient
placement I
think didn't see nothing couldn't see
nothing there was all this red goo in
the way someone was like devouring jelly
donuts right outside this window here as
they were probably peeping inside not my
problem though I my oh my truck I
thought my truck was gone
of course not that'd be
[Music]
silly yum yum yump
y damn I'm good at my job there is a lot
of
bedrooms more business for me I
guess
[Music]
now that's something
special any who am I done there's
another oh oh oh oh oh oh this is some
truck I guess I didn't need to get any
more leaning
Supply I'm at least very thorough in my
job I told you I've seen a lot as a
window cleaner I've seen the craziest
most Unholy acts of orgasmic Delight the
likes of which would make
uh make the devil
blush and I wouldn't tell
Soul that's is the kind of professional
I
am anyway
you
see my
God
five stars great discretion a little
cleaning
surface we need some window cleaning is
it just looping back
again oh oh I
see
ah
now it all makes
sense makes perfect sense great I
actually liked it a lot that was very
fun it was a fun little way to do kind
of a showcase uh cycle of Horrors thing
in a different way that I've never seen
and it was very satisfying to uh clean
things up so I can't fault that that was
really nice I liked it a lot thank you
everybody so much for watching if you
want to check out late night mop Li game
I'll link it in the description it's
more cleaning based horror fun can't go
wrong with that thank you and as always
I will see you in the next video
byebye